[Music]
i'm rupert sheldrake
i'm a biologist and i'm the author of
several books including ways to go
beyond and why they work the most recent
one
let's talk about ways to go beyond what
led you to start writing it
i'm interested in science because i'm a
scientist
i'm also interested in a range of
spiritual practices because i do them
myself
and i lived in india for seven years and
so i've been learned a lot when i was
there of different kinds of practices
so i've written two books actually the
first thought is called science and
spiritual practices and ways to go
beyond is a sequel
a kind of culmination of this project
and in the book i discuss seven
different spiritual practices
which can lead to us feeling more
connected
uh with something greater than ourselves
that's what spiritual practices do
and the first chapter is on sports which
many people find surprising but um
is i think the way in which most people
in modern britain
achieve some state of going beyond
themselves a kind of
altered state of consciousness and one
of the things about participating in
sports
is that it completely shuts down the
default mode network that region of the
brain that's to do with the chattering
mind the internal dialogue
meditation is also about shutting down
the default mode network but sports work
faster
you know if you're as one friend of mine
who's a mountaineer said
you know by the time he's 50 feet up a
rock face he was completely in the
present
um and if you're in the middle of a
football game you're totally in the
present
if you're skiing downhill at 60 miles an
hour you go around a corner there's an
obstacle in the way
you have to be totally in the present
and i think that's one reason that
extreme sports uh and dangerous sports
are so popular today because
they make people totally in the present
if your concentration lapses for a
second or two you're dead
so i think sports are one kind of
spiritual practice
many people do them because they feel
they get in the flow
in a sense of being part of a flow
greater than just themselves
the second practice i discuss is
learning from animals and again most
people don't think of that as a
spiritual practice
um but one of the points of spiritual
practices is
coming into the present as i said the
default mode network
takes us into this constant chattering
mind anxiety fears
judgments fantasies and so on um
but animals don't have that problem if a
cat's
powering because you're stroking it
sitting contentedly on your lap
it's totally in the present and so we
can learn from animals
uh quite a few different things but one
of them is being in the present
so can you can you connect being in the
present to
what you earlier said about going beyond
which is being conscious of something
greater or bigger or being involved in
something larger than you are
well i think it's a common experience
that if you come
completely into the present then the
only way you can feel
the presence of a greater consciousness
is in the present
and um just being in the present
fully in the present is for most people
a kind of spiritual experience
all mystical experiences are about being
completely present
and our normal state of mind is
discursive chatter you know we're
thinking about what we do next or
what we ought to have done yesterday and
that kind of thing so this is constant
internal chat
that always takes us away from the
present i once saw a gameboy advert on
the tube and it said
wherever you are be somewhere else and
you know there's the exact opposite of
the principle of be here now which is a
key feature of spiritual practices
next is fasting and fasting isn't
in itself uh bringing you into the
present um
but what it's doing is clearing the mind
and body i mean fasting is present in
all religions it's also done
for health reasons in a purely secular
context
and when you fast the levels of
so-called ketone bodies go up in your
blood particularly
beta-hydroxybutyric acid bhb
which is very closely related to
gamma-aminobutyric acid gaba which is
the main neurotransmitter in the brain
and gbh gamma ghb
gamma hydroxybutyric acid these are
neurotransmitters
so fasting is psychoactive and um
people who fast find their mind often
becomes clearer their dreams more vivid
so fasting is a way of actually changing
your mind
in a way that's free in fact not only
free you actually save money
and it changes your whole sense of
reality the
time of days open up it's easier to
meditate easier to pray
that's why it's been part of spiritual
practices in all religious traditions
the next chapter is on psychedelics and
cannabis
because i think for many people in the
modern world
they provide a spiritual opening a kind
of rite of passage for a lot of young
people
taking a psychedelic is opens a realm of
consciousness
they didn't know existed it certainly
had that effect on me when i first took
nsd in
1970 and
the i think psychedelics
in some cultures are used shamanically
like ayahuasca in the amazon
mushrooms in mexico iboga in west africa
as part of kind of rites of passage
and moving into a different state of
being so i think they're playing a major
spiritual role in the modern world
actually and that's
why i have a chapter on this subject um
and then i discuss prayer which is
the obviously more mainstream than
learning from animals or
even fasting i mean lots of people pray
and what's going on when you're praying
there's a lot of studies that show
scientific studies that show that people
who pray are generally speaking happier
healthier and live longer than those
that don't
and you could say this is just a kind of
placebo effect
um but even if you do say that then
um placebo effects work you know it's
the best documented of all effects in
medicine it happens in every
kind of drug or surgical trial you get
placebo effects
and so anything that enhances placebo
effects is going to work better than
something that doesn't
and it may be much more than that and
for people who pray there's
often a sense of connection with a
greater realm of consciousness
um and i pray myself all these practices
things i do myself so
they're all ones that i personally think
work at least work for me
then i have a whole chapter on holy days
and festivals
which are present in all religious
traditions and indeed secular traditions
and the whole point of holy days and
festivals is that holy days are holidays
i mean it's the same word basically um
and a holiday for there to be a holy day
it has to be a holiday because it has to
be a day when you're not working
to celebrate it and the whole point of
holy days and festivals is that
everyone or nearly everyone has a
holiday at the same time
so you can celebrate together um
if you have a 24 7 culture where
people are given random times off they
work on saturdays and sundays and on
christmas day and boxing day and that
kind of thing they're given the sort of
next tuesday off instead
in terms of time they may get the same
time off but the quality of the time is
much less because everyone's working
them
it completely loses their sense of
collective celebration which is very
important for us
all and i think that's one reason why
summer festivals
have as it were reinvented the
traditional festival
which used to happen in the middle ages
in england the puritans weren't very
keen on them so a lot of them were
suppressed
but i think they've been reinvented in
the form of summer music festivals
and to some degree in the form of how
the light gets in
um which only work because people are
free to come
at the same time and and um
and then i the i have a chapter on um
cultivating virtues avoiding vices and
being kind
you know there's a kind of morality
which is important in all these things
because
if it's just a matter of feeling good
through taking psychedelics or doing
yoga or something
then it's not necessarily helping anyone
else so it could be seen as a purely
spiritual a purely selfish practice
rather than spiritual
the scientific community hasn't
necessarily welcomed what you've had to
say as scientific
do you want to be recognized scientific
do you think the modern scientific
community is
unwilling to look beyond its own
boundaries
at the moment the official scientific
worldview is dominated by the philosophy
of
mechanistic materialism the doctrine
that nature's dead
nature's inanimate animals and plants
and machines and so
we um that mind's nothing but the brain
that evolution is purposeless this is
the belief system that dominates modern
science
and i think is played a part in creating
the ecological crisis
and so it's not just an intellectual
belief system
and i think it's profoundly mistaken and
that's why
a lot of my scientific work has been
trying to
go beyond that limited world view my
book the science delusion
looks at the 10 principal assumptions of
mechanistic materialism
and shows that they're basically not
very scientific they're just
assumptions and if we turn those
assumptions into questions
we can test them scientifically then
science can move on
it's by closing down questioning that
science gets stuck
and so some people who are great
believers in mechanistic materialism
usually militant atheists are the people
who've got the biggest investment in
this worldview
get very angry at what i'm doing and
attack it and say it's pseudoscience and
so forth but um
there are a lot of people in the
scientific world who agree with me that
we need to move on that there's a
growing movement for example in
philosophy of mind
of pan psychism the idea there's a kind
of mind or consciousness throughout
nature
we don't just live in a dead inanimate
mechanistic universe that
nature's more like an organism than a
machine
and so um there are many people in the
scientific world who actually want this
kind of change to happen i'm not the
only person advocating it
i may be one of the ones who's more in
the public eye than others and
it's partly because i've got nothing to
lose i i say what i think
whereas the scientific world is full of
people who are kind of closet
supporters of a change towards a more
animistic or penn psychist view of
nature a more holistic approach to
science
most of them keep quiet because they
don't want to lose their jobs or
not get their next grant application
renewed or
spoil their chance of a better postdoc
than they've got at the moment
so many of them keep quiet i i'm
constantly approached by scientists
i meet under clandestine circumstances
who tell me how much they too want
science to change but they can't say so
to their colleagues
and so it's certainly not the case that
the entire scientific community is
opposed to
changing from mechanistic materialism a
lot of people would love this change to
happen
and it is actually happening there's a
move towards pan psychism
i think partly through people taking
psychedelics it
often leads to people shifting their
worldview from
extreme mechanistic materialism to
something more
uh and psychos well if you can also
prove that people who are playing sport
are moving
towards that then yeah you might be on
to a winner there i think
i think it's harder for most people
playing sports it's harder to get that
pan psyches dimension but i think
i think that might be possible yes i
remember the last time you played sunday
league
um i have never played chandra league
[Laughter]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv